but of course before we go we always  have some good vibes for you and today  they're brought to you by john lennon's  son julian this is beautiful yeah the  son of the late beatles legend performed  imagine for the first time ever in  support of global citizens stand up for  ukraine campaign  yeah and in the uh youtube description  of the video julian wrote this the song  reflects the light at the end of the  tunnel that we are all hoping for i'd  always said that the only time i would  ever consider singing imagine would be  if it was the end of the world the war  in ukraine is an unimaginable tragedy as  a human and as an artist i felt  compelled to respond in the most  significant way i could and of course  for more information and ways to donate  and help support the people of ukraine  visit globalcitizen.org  bye everyone bye  imagine there's no heaven  it's easy if you  try  [Music]  [Music]  imagine all the  people  living  for today  [Music]